[MUSIC]
Why do you do what you do?
What creates a sense of purpose for you?
Is it working?
Volunteering?
Being with your family?
These are not trivial questions.
Research shows that having a strong sense
of purpose creates more meaning in life,
improves health and
leads to greater satisfaction from work.
Purpose needs intention.
Having a stable far reaching goal.
When we're pursuing our purpose,
we feel our lives are more meaningful.
Now meaning is an abstract concept.
But recently, behavioral scientists
have made progress toward
understanding it better and
even measuring it.
I recently conducted
a study with my colleagues,
Roy Baumeister, Kathleen Vohs and
Emily Garbinsky, where we
asked adults to rate on a seven-point
scale whether their lives were meaningful.
[SOUND] We also asked about their beliefs,
behaviors, and choices.
Those who deem their lives most meaningful
were those who gave the most to others.
These same people also felt the most
strongly connected to the past and
future, not just the here and now.
They had a strong sense of
where they came from, and
an equally strong sense of where
they are going, a purpose.
So the feeling of meaning increases
when we feel connected to others and
something bigger than ourselves.
When we feel we're part of a story
that started in the past and
concludes well into the future.
What's more, meaning is not something
you just have or don't have.
It's more about your mindset.
When individuals adopt a meaning mindset
they behave in very different ways.
In one study two researchers,
Veronika Huta and
Richard Ryan, had half of their
subjects adopt a meaning mind set by
asking them to do one thing
each day to create meaning.
These activities, like strengthening a
social connection, pursuing excellence, or
helping others often required effort.
Yet three months later, these subjects
reported less negative moods and
more positive feelings about
their social connections.
Suggesting that meaning
can decrease stress and
boost well-being in the long run.
As people find more meaning in their
lives, they also tend to get healthier.
Psychologist Carol Ryff and
her colleagues demonstrated this
in a study that tracked
thousands of people over time.
The people living more meaningful lives,
by their own account, were
healthier than those who, while happy,
did not have the same sense of meaning.
The high meaning people had higher levels
of good cholesterol, healthier weight,
they even slept better.
They had lower levels of cortisol,
the stress hormone in their saliva.
And were lower risk for cardiovascular
disease and Alzheimer's disease.
They also live longer.
To figure out why, researchers had
subjects report their levels of meaning,
and then put the subjects
into an fMRI machine.
Then they show them images of
negative things like crying babies or
car accidents.
The participants then rated whether
the images were neutral or unpleasant.
The brain scans show that the high meaning
people had less activity in the amygdala,
the part of the brain that processes fear.
They also reacted more slowly
to the negative images,
taking longer to decide whether
the pictures were unpleasant.
In other words, people with high
meaning in life are better able,
with the help of their prefrontal
cortex,to control their negative emotions.
They're better able at putting
things in perspective.
These findings have implications for
work too.
People who feel their work lacks
meaning are more likely to slack off or
feel dissatisfied with their employers.
The problem is, most people
feel this way about their work.
At least, that was the case
in one large-scale study,
which tracked over 12,000 employees
across a broad range of categories and
showed 50 percent lacked
a sense of meaning at work.
The employees who did derive meaning from
their work were more than 3 times as
likely to stay with their companies
They also reported 1.7 times higher job
satisfaction, and
were 1.4 times more engaged at work.
Which brings us back to the original
question: why do you do what you do?
If you work only for the money, chances
are you're less effective than you can be.
But if your answer entails meaning,
your work help should become part of a
bigger story and feel connected to others,
then it will help you be stronger,
healthier and more resilient.
[SOUND]